[Music]
well every time you cried in the film it
just set me off like I cried too so my
question is do you have any tricks on
how to get the crying it's funny it's
like I am I'm empathic I guess like I I
can if I can connect to someone's pain
it doesn't make I don't have to have
tricks like I actually feel I cry a lot
in life just in general too so it's not
a it has it's never been really
difficult for me oh my that just just
destroys me the the our green version of
a change gonna come for whatever reason
now what it is that song just beats on
me yeah what about you guys I was
talking about it I think it's like
actors just have like this powerful
imagination to really just kind of read
something and then like and we also kind
of feed off each other you know you know
in a scene where if someone else isn't
really into it you just kinda it's keep
trading that energy and that just
happens to just work and you don't even
know like people don't realize that when
they're watching a scene and they see
someone crying what is more painful is
that we're actually trying not to cry
and it's like that struggle to try not
to cry is what you know hits the pain in
the audience yeah as an actor you just
take yourself all the way to that space
and when you go on-camera you're
actually you're trying to restrain and
that restraint is excruciating
it wasn't that wasn't a joke
it wasn't funny will you crying you on
camera you can turn your strength in
some of our favorite Christmas movies
that glamour mm-hmm so what we want to
ask you guys is are you team Love
Actually or team the holiday you always
this singer as well as an actor
is there anything do you look is he
someone that you'd look up to absolutely
yeah hit Myers me deeply you say cut we
just like cool and we you know we
hanging out and having a good time they
say action is just like tom is important
just get right into definitely difficult
I mean cuz offset we were arguing along
[Music]
my question is do you have an obviously
about loss and grief and this year has
to make 2017 way more positive you know
I have a really interesting perspective
about pain and grief I think that sort
of suffering tends to precipitate joy
you know they're like bound in a really
interesting way you know I've never
really struggled to find joy in all
kinds of situations you know so to me to
me when I look at 2016 there was a there
was a lot of turmoil in the world but it
always felt like a good thing you know I
felt like a cleansing I felt like the
the you know a little bit of dark before
the dawn